good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
recently nerdfighters have been asking
me a lot about this don't forget to be
awesome rug available at Urban
Outfitters like did we license it no are
they paying us no are we happy about it
not really can we stop them yes
but we're not going to welcome to the
wild world of trademarks so first I
think urban outfitters is not alone in
this co-opting of dftba like there's
this Kate Spade wallet that says don't
forget to be awesome as does this Hobby
Lobby poster and this Delius t-shirt and
this arrow post style ad has also this
thing from Pier one stuff from Ranjan
surf shop mag I know that we did not
invent the phrase don't forget to be
awesome so far as I know it was invented
by my friend Katie else in 2007 however
we did popularize it the phrase had
almost no Google hits or searches before
nerdfighters began using it and Hank
because the phrase is so closely
associated with us it would be easy
enough for us to go and hire a lawyer
and trade market and then we could send
Urban Outfitters a cease and desist
letter that would be like hi
either stop selling this doormat or else
publicly apologize for firing all of
your Swedish employees when they
attempted to unionize and I would kind
of like to do that partly because I
don't want corporations co-opting
nerdfighteria and partly because I am
tired of getting emails asking me why
for instance nerdfighter slogans are
available at Hobby Lobby a corporation
that until like a month ago refused to
carry menorahs ah but wait here is the
problem with trademarks you cannot
selectively enforce them
so Hank if we trademark dftba and don't
forget to be awesome we can't just tell
obon Outfitters and Hobby Lobby to stop
making don't forget to be awesome stuff
we have to tell everyone to stop using
that phrase including like nerdfighters
who make awesome stuff and sell it on
Etsy like I'd have to send cease and
desist letters to the people who made
this amazing spoon or these hank
corphish greeting cards or this dftba
scarf God's awesome and I don't want to
do that because I don't want that stuff
to stop existing in fact in many cases I
want to personally buy it but if we
selectively enforce our trademark than
urban outfitters in Hobby Lobby can be
like no no no no no this isn't really
trademarked because what they don't care
when those people use the phrase so the
only way to stop even Outfitters from
selling dftba rugs is to also stop
nerdfighters from selling dftba scarves
and of course that's bananas you
couldn't explain this to any court but
the truth is that the phrase don't
forget to be awesome doesn't belong to
you and me Hank it belongs to
nerdfighteria so Hank we aren't going to
trademark don't forget to be awesome
because it would mean claiming ownership
over something that isn't really ours
and that means that occasionally we're
going to have to deal with companies
trying to co-op the sayings of the
nerdfighter community but Hank I suspect
the vast majority of nerdfighters will
continue to make their own dftba stuff
or else buy from independent creators or
buy it at dftba.com where the royalties
from nerdfighter merchandise are always
shared with the nerdfighters who design
that stuff anyway I want to say one more
thing about trademark because it totally
fascinates me if you had a lot of other
people use your trademark and it becomes
weakened it can eventually become what's
called genericized and that is every
brands nightmare like aspirin used to be
trademarked by the company that
distributed it Bayer and that meant that
only bear could call the receipt of
silic acid aspirin the way that only
advil can call their ibuprofen advil but
because the aspirin trademark weakened
over time and everyone just started
calling that drug aspirin now anyone can
call their aspirin aspirin the same
thing happened to escalator and thermos
and it almost happened to some brands we
know pretty well today including
Nintendo which marketed the phrase game
console so people wouldn't call all
consoles Nintendo's and to Google which
is why Google is always very careful to
talk about searching even when the rest
of us always talk about googling and
companies like Nintendo and Google are
terrified of their trademarks becoming
genericized because those trademarks
define them but our community is lucky
enough to be defined not by its name or
by its mottos but by the values those
words represent and those values don't
become less meaningful when they are
shared in fact quite the contrary Hank
I'll see you on Friday